as expected shrieking abortion
supporters showed up at brett
kavanaugh's home over the weekend to
scare his kids and to try to intimidate
the justice into changing his vote on
the dobbs case to overrule roe v wade
[Applause]
the only reason the mob didn't show up
to the home of justice sam alito who
wrote the leaked opinion is because the
threats against him were so severe that
the entire family was moved to an
undisclosed location the angry mob was
expected at kavanaugh's house as well as
the homes of the other conservative
justices because last week after
a leftist activist leaked the decision a
left-wing organization doxed the
justices and published their home
addresses then when the white house was
asked about the leak and the doxing the
press secretary refused to condemn the
mobs speaking on behalf of the president
jensaki actually said that people are
passionate and that the white house
didn't have any official position on
where people protest
you can't even really call that tacit
approval sake was asked directly to call
off the dogs at least to voice some
modest disapproval of the mob showing up
at the judge's homes
and she shrugged her shoulders
this latest series of threats and
intimidation against the conservative
justices families and children is no
surprise because as i pointed out the
moment the leak occurred
we are talking about people who kill
little babies
there is no norm they will not violate
there is no depth to which they will not
sink
they know that the supreme court reads
the election returns and the opinion
polls and they hear the mobs outside so
they're trying to pressure them to
switch their votes but there is a silver
lining to this storm cloud
a silver lining that i also predicted
last week you know that i hate to say i
told you so that is that the political
effect of the leak and the threats and
the mobs is favorable
to republicans favorable to
conservatives favorable
to life i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from arthur devane who
says my bride never worked for wages
outside the home during the kids
formative years whenever anyone brought
up that old saw about her not being paid
for all the work that she did i would
reply oh no i give her every cent that i
own this is a great point happy mother's
day to all the mothers out there i
remember during the 2020 presidential
race during the democrat primary andrew
yang would always go on and on about how
his wife was not paid for her work
and i thought one i don't know give your
wife more money i don't know what's
wrong with you andrew wang but but uh
andrew yang rather but second of all
why do we need to quantify every single
thing why does everything need to be
brought into the monetary economy
historically speaking mothers wives have
more political power than anybody john
wayne said that america was a matriarchy
the hand that rocks the cradle is the
hand that rules the world not everything
can be quantified and economized and put
down on a spreadsheet okay especially
the work that mothers do so happy
mother's day to everybody when you want
to hire people who can be quantified and
monetized you got to check out
ziprecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
knowles there are people in my life that
i rely on first and foremost my wife
right it was just mother's day what
would i do i'd be living in a gutter
without sweet little alisa then far down
the list after that i don't know my
producer my assistant my everybody at
this company if they if any one of them
stop doing their job i would be i would
be babbling incoherently more so than
already which is why you need
ziprecruiter okay zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire time is money
personnel is policy the most important
investment you're gonna make in your
company is going to be in the people you
can try it for free right now at
ziprecruiter.com slash
knowles they use powerful matching
technology
to find the right candidates match them
up for your job they then recommend the
candidates to you you can look through
your top picks invite the top choices to
apply you're not just throwing spaghetti
at the wall they're actively going out
there four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a high quality
candidate within the first day
right now the hardest thing you got to
do is just remember this url
ziprecruiter.com knowles that's where
you go to try zip recruiter for free zip
recruiter dot com slash canon wlis zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
lots of mostly peaceful protests going
on over the weekend
mostly peaceful threats against the
children of conservative supreme court
justices mostly peaceful angry mobs
outside the private homes of supreme
court justices and more and more
thankfully kavanaugh's family seems to
be safe john roberts family seems to be
safe but i thought when i saw the
protests first occur i said why are they
focusing on kavanaugh
sam alito is the one who wrote the
opinion why why aren't we seeing the
mobs oh because sam alito's family was
moved into hiding because the threats
against him were so much worse than the
threats against brett kavanaugh
was this just overreacting sam he would
have been fine right well i'm not so
sure i i think it probably would have
gotten pretty violent here's my evidence
a pro-life group was hit with molotov
cocktails
over the weekend a wisconsin pro-life
group's office
was set on fire early sunday morning i
was vandalized with abortion themed
graffiti in in what the police are
calling an arson
i was the wisconsin family action
headquarters uh there was fire damage
there were flames coming out of the
building at 6 a.m and there was a spray
painted message which said if abortions
aren't safe then you aren't either
fortunately no injuries were reported
the first question you got to ask
yourself whenever an incident like this
happens is is it real or is it a hoax
we've seen a ton of hoaxes
uh racial hoaxes sexual hoaxes we've
seen a lot of hoaxes from the left
threats of racist graffiti and things
like that 99 times out of 100 they turn
out to be fake
is this fake here
i don't think so i don't think so and
it's not just because i'm biased on my
side the right wing it's just if you
look at these sorts of incidents
they are almost if not always
hoaxes on the left
you don't really see those i could write
i actually have a full chapter in my
book on all these kind of racial and
sexual and just political hoaxes from
the left you just don't really see them
from the right
and and then you get to the second part
which is the left gets violent and the
right generally does not get violent i'm
not saying that there are no exceptions
to this but if you look at incidents of
violence particularly in recent years
political violence
it's almost entirely on the left
it's not on the right
would the left really do these sorts of
things i don't know you remember 2020
remember when the left burned the
country down coast to coast for eight
months yeah i think they probably would
throw a molotov cocktail into
into a pro-life headquarters
office actually they did that sort of
thing for more than half of a year two
years ago
so we're talking about real threats i'm
glad no one was injured here i'm glad it
was an empty office i'm glad it wasn't
one of the conservative judges houses
but clearly the left is trying to scare
the conservative judges into believing
it could be in their houses
when jen saki said the government we
have no we have no official government
position on where people protest go get
them gosh nice house you got there
justice kavanaugh justice alito sure it
would be a shame if something happened
to it it's no different than than what
the mob would say when they walk into
your business with a protection racket
the only difference is they're they're
actually talking about these people's
homes where their children sleep
the the only silver lining here i mean
this is really really disgusting stuff
it's bad in and of itself for the
families of the judges
but it's bad for democracy i never again
want to hear about our our sacred
democracy and the sacred norms and rule
of law that the insurrect give me a
break you're telling me that january 6
was the worst event in the history of
the country because a horn hat guy
danced around the capital rotunda but
that sicking an angry mob on the
justices homes where their kids sleep
because you don't like an opinion that's
coming out that's totally fine that's
democracy in action shove it man go you
know go pound sand if that's going to be
your argument i never want to hear it
again about january 6th the great's a
joke it's a complete joke and you're
going to hear later on this summer
you're going to hear all of the january
6th
crocodile tears you're going to see it
from not just the liberals but from a
couple of the court jester conservatives
liz cheney adam kinzinger this is it
it's done you show up to the judge's
houses you threaten the family of the
judges i never want to hear another word
about january 6. not that i wanted to
hear anything about it before the silver
lining here though
this is really backfiring this is really
not working for the libs there is a poll
out
showing the political effect uh forget
about the mobs this is just the
political effect of the leaked decision
okay the i think the mobs are actually
gonna move this even more in the
conservative direction but this poll is
not from the daily wire it's not from
fox news it's not from some right-wing
outlet
it's from cnn
cnn shows
that the over-ruling of roe and the leak
of the decision
not only will not help democrats in
november but will actually help
republicans
there the share of registered voters who
say they are extremely or very
enthusiastic about voting in the
midterms rose six percentage points
after the leak of the of the decision
among democrats 43 say they are now
extremely are very enthusiastic about
the midterms that's up seven points
so it seems like democrats got a boost
except that
right now the percentage of republicans
who say they're very excited about the
midterms is 56
so it's much higher than the democrats
and it's up nine points since the league
the voters who say that overturning row
would make them happy are nearly twice
as enthusiastic about voting in the
midterms
as those who say their ruling would
leave them angry
i
you know
you know i hate to say i told you so but
i i had my ultra damas hat on i had my
crystal ball out i said guys
not only is over ruling row the right
thing to do
not only does the leak show that the
libs are really desperate
but it's a political winner as well you
heard some of the squishes saying oh no
why do we have to overrule rho in the
midterms oh no this is just going to
help the democrats this is going to take
away our momentum we had all the
momentum on the economy and immigration
and foreign policy now we're all going
to squander it to save those babies
you're not going to squander it it's
going to help you you if you think that
if you and the squishes believe that
abortion is a losing issue for
conservatives it's because you have
bought the propaganda from the left
which which wants to make us all believe
that america is full of a bunch of
bloodthirsty maniacs who want to kill
babies up until the moment of birth the
conservative position on abortion is not
the fringe position
it's the mainstream position don't kill
babies is the mainstream normal popular
position abortion on demand without
apology into the fifth trimester that is
a fringe view that's the radical view
okay people don't like that
don't buy the propaganda
this is going to be a big big win
it's the right thing to do first of all
but it's going to be a big big win for
conservatives this issue is backing the
libs and the democrats into a corner
even the most practiced democrats even
the smoothest operators out there
they have no answer on the abortion
question that's why that's why they're
trying to distract they're saying
actually the roe v wade overruling this
is really about contraception this is
really about interracial marriage i kid
you not there you remember eric swallow
said this is really about interracial
marriage what the hell are you talking
about interracial marriage for that has
nothing to do with abortion oh you're
talking about that because you know that
your position on abortion is deeply
unpopular it's got me feeling good it's
got me feeling healthy you know what
else makes you feel healthy superbeads
right now go to superbeats.com knowles
because i've got a new way to start your
day that is super beets heart chews they
are a tasty treat that gives you the
energy you need and are good for you no
more afternoon coffees no more energy
drinks no more candy for that quick
pick-me-up
two delicious plant-based super beets
heart shoes are all you need for your
morning routine to promote heart-healthy
energy for your day without a caffeine
crash super beets heart shoes unique
clinically researched grape seed extract
promote heart healthy energy and normal
blood pressure as part of a healthy
lifestyle the grape seed extract used in
super beets art shoes has been
clinically shown to be twice as
effective at supporting normal blood
pressure as a healthy lifestyle alone do
more for your heart and treat yourself
with super beats heart shoes
i love super beats heart shoes my only
complaint about them is that every time
they arrive at the daily wire these
jackals these hyenas these animals here
go in and take all of them before i can
get my fistful so go in right now you
can save up to 45
plus free shipping at superbeats.com
knowles this is their best offer
available anywhere superbeats.com slash
knowles up to 45 off
superbeats.com knowles these statements
and products have not been evaluated by
the food and drug administration these
products are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease or
condition
elizabeth warren lyawtha herself who got
red in the face who was so angry that
the supreme court might overrule roe v
wade you saw a fire in her eyes you saw
this fear that she no longer will be
able to sacrifice all of those babies to
her demon god quetzalcoatl she saw her
fingers just itching for the hatchet but
but the conservative judges were going
to take that hatchet away from her well
elizabeth warren
is
changing her tune a little bit
she's still radically pro-abortion but
she realizes that her her bloodlust to
kill these babies is not really playing
very well in peoria and so elizabeth
warren now was asked a question point
blank should there be any limits on
abortion
and she dodged the question
there's a question should there be any
limits on abortions you know
i'm going to put it this way i think
that the woman who is most affected
should be at the heart of this of course
i think that she should be able to call
on
her partner right
her mother
um her priest her rabbi
she should be able to bring in the
people she needs
but in a pregnancy i don't believe that
it is the state that should intervene
with its heavy hand
and make the decision
that's a whole lot of words to say no
it's a simple question should there be
any limits whatsoever on abortion
and her answer is no she thinks you
should be able to kill babies up until
the moment of birth at least
and she knows that that is insane and
evil and radical and doesn't sit very
well with voters and so she has to go on
this word salad for three minutes to say
well and i think a woman
should talk to her partner
and uh her
priest that's not going to go very well
darling have you have you read the
catechism of the church and never mind
and she should and the decision it's the
same answer ralph northam hey should we
be able to kill babies on the operating
table well now i think that we should in
that in a case where a baby is born and
the mama doesn't want it we're gonna
make it comfortable and then maybe we're
gonna let it be and we're gonna kill it
okay and you just they just ramble on
and on you just give the honest answer
no you don't think there should be any
limits
to abortion
whatsoever
and then she has the audacity this is
the funniest funniest part of it all she
says i don't think that the heavy hand
of government
should be involved this is the this is
the only issue in politics that
elizabeth warren has ever come across
where she does not believe that the
heavy hand of government should be
involved it's the only one she wants to
regulate your light bulbs okay she wants
to regulate everything with every end of
government except whether or not you
should be able to kill an innocent
little baby it's so disingenuous it's so
radical it's so off-putting
there is no
you can just tell watching this woman
listening to her i think how sh this
woman is not ever going to be the
president
her i think those dreams are dashed and
then you listen to the position more
broadly say this this party that's
running on this issue
is not going to win
in a fair election there's no way they
win
rosanna arquette
she's a very
excitable lib in hollywood
rosanna arquette holds the same radical
position on abortion as elizabeth warren
but she's more excitable about it she
she is more hysterical about it
this is what she said over the weekend
quote no it's not hysterical or alarmist
they the conservatives the and the
conservative supreme court judges will
traffic babies that many women can't
afford to keep there is a huge
money-making market worldwide for babies
and behind that is organ trafficking the
majority supreme court justices are
officially the satanic force
the funny thing about this
quasi-grammatical semi-coherent claim
is that rosanna arquette and the libs
broadly are accusing the conservatives
of doing exactly what they themselves
are doing what are she makes two claims
here
she says that the conservatives want to
traffic flesh they want to they want to
traffic living human beings in some kind
of what
sex trade or something like that
in some some kind of slavery trade and
they want to traffic
baby body parts so dead human beings
they want to sell them on the black
market planned parenthood officials have
been caught on hidden camera multiple
times repeatedly
haggling for the price of selling baby
body parts
not even just one official multiple
planned parenthood officials the the
campaign was the center for medical
progress david deliden went in
undercover because planned parenthood
said no we're not selling baby body
parts the body parts of aborted babies
in our clinics and then he went
undercover in meetings with multiple
officials and they were all haggling
over the price because they said yes we
will sell these body parts to you
they even made jokes about it they said
well i'm not going to i'm not going to
give you my number first you need to
tell me your price first i want to buy a
lamborghini hahaha
there there is
documents footage audio from meetings of
player planned parenthood officials
saying that they do this very same thing
that roseanne arquette is accusing the
conservatives of doing
furthermore she's saying what about just
the
black market in selling people you know
just regular old human trafficking of
living human beings
which side is it that's trying to
legalize prostitution which side which
it's the libs it's the libs the
everything
that they
are accusing us of they do themselves
it's classic
projection it's it's a good rule of
thumb in politics whatever the libs are
screaming about conservatives allegedly
doing it's a safe bet that they
themselves are doing it speaking of
defending the indefensible on camera
the white house is getting a new press
secretary that press secretary will be
karin jean-pierre
she it was the deputy for gensake she
was somehow less impressive than jen
saki jensaki had a few moments of
zingers a few moments that were kind of
funny uh corrine jean-pierre so far has
been extremely unimpressive in the job
but now jinsaki is going to go make
make some money over at msnbc so kareem
jumpier is stepping in here's what jen
saki had to say about the appointment of
karine jean-pierre to be the press
secretary
i'm reading it exactly in order this is
just what she said
lots to say about how grateful i am to
the president first lady in the biden
family for trusting me to serve as press
secretary and plenty of time before my
last day to share but today is about
corrine john pierre so a few thoughts on
this remarkable woman who will soon be
behind the podium every day she will be
the first black woman and first openly
lgbtq plus person to serve as the white
house press secretary representation
matters and she will give a voice to
many but also make many dream big about
what is truly possible uh karine
jean-pierre has decades of experience
from her early years working in
government politics in new york to her
years as an outspoken advocate to
serving as a longtime advisor to the
president when he was vice president
so let me translate that for you
she says today is about green john
pierre
the first thing i'm going to say about
her is that she is black and she has
unusual sexual appetites
that's we is so wonderful that this
woman is the press secretary because of
the color of her skin and her sexual
appetites that's why this is so great
also she's got some experience
but most importantly of all did i don't
know if i mentioned this yet she is
black and
is sexually attracted to women
i think is that what i don't even know
what which letter of the lgbtq uh karine
jean-pierre is
but
anyway she's got some kind of eccentric
sexual appetite and that's the most
important thing it's it's an
acknowledgement that
this woman is another diversity hire
she's a diversity hire just like the
biden those that's not my words i'm not
the one saying it it's jen saki said
that
if this woman were being hired for her
merit
then jan saki would have reversed the
tweets
she would have said this woman has so
much experience she brings so much skill
and talent to the table and also she's
black and sexually attracted to women
but that's not what gensake did it's
it's the same pattern we've seen from
the biden administration
the the reason we need to nominate
katanji jackson of the supreme court is
she is extremely black and i would note
a woman
and also she went to harvard and you
know she's got a lot of experience
but i am only going to pick a black
woman that is all i care about i'm not
going to pick the most qualified person
i'm only going to look at black women
and exclude other candidates who might
be more qualified
biden did the same thing with vice
president he said i am going to pick a
black woman to be my vice president
so
all you've excluded
what 94 of the country at that point and
in terms of prominent black women who
were up for that job in 2020 you had
three women
karen bass who's an actual communist
member of congress you had
uh susan rice the fall man for benghazi
and you had kamala harris who was the
first person out of the democrat
presidential primary but somehow she was
the best choice because you limited your
options to three
okay and michelle obama probably didn't
want the job
so that's it you've got
that's what they're saying i think
that's ugly i think that's unfortunate i
think it would be nice if when people
get big jobs in the government they can
say it was because of their merit
they're not just looked at as tokens and
not just looked at as diversity hires
but the biden administration clearly
looks at this woman as a diversity hire
just look at the statement from the
president's spokesman and i love jinzaki
says representation matters
yes representation in our national
government matters that's true i want i
want my voice to be heard in the
national government
i don't care if someone
who vaguely looks like me physically is
in the government
i don't i don't in fact i wouldn't like
it if rachel maddow were working in the
federal government that would upset me
in fact one of my favorite people in the
government is clarence thomas i don't
look very much like clarence thomas i
was going to say sam alito but i
actually do kind of look like sam alito
you know the italians we stick together
but clarence thomas i love clarence
thomas does that mean i don't really
look like him amy barrett seems to be
doing a pretty good job at least i don't
really look like amy barrett do i
no that representation does not matter
to me
i don't i don't think it is a matter of
political importance that we have lots
of lesbians in the government i don't
think that i i want people in the
government to be nice to lesbians i
don't
i don't want lesbians or other minority
groups to be to be unfairly targeted or
any but
this does not matter because there's no
end to that by the way you know we joke
about how the acronym lgbt just keeps
expanding and there's no end to the
expand expanding and so if we're saying
that we need someone from every single
group many of which are being created
every single day to be represented in
the government there's simply no end to
that
now speaking of representation
you all represented my book very very
beautifully speechless on uh over the
weekend we said that in honor of the
1000 episode we were going to give away
a
big big prize some kind of gif gift bag
or something like that
four people
who went over left a five star review so
my favorite comment
the winner of the of the prize is the
shuckmeister
who wrote on amazon a book that will
play well in peoria adorned on my shelf
with the american classics is a signed
copy of speechless controlling words
controlling minds ding reading this book
feels like the culmination of nearly one
thousand episodes of wisdom from the one
and only michael dinoldstradamus a
thoroughly researched work of literature
it juxtaposes the historical nature
culture and meaning of linguistics with
a modern culture that seeks to uproot
that foundation with recent events like
elon musk's twitter takeover the thesis
of the book is more relevant than ever
and lessons can be taken to ensure we
not only have the ability to speak
freely but have something substantial to
say as well with the countless
recommendations i've given to friends
and family this book certainly had not
has not left me speechless thank you
very much that's very kind of you
whatever the gift thing is that the
producers came up with we will be sure
to send that out to you and i'm really
glad the point you made there is so
important
with elon taking over twitter with us as
the conservatives maybe getting a little
more political power
it's really important not to throw our
hands up in the air and do the old shrug
and and say we're not going to do
anything with that political power we
got to use it folks we got to use it to
help take our culture back
now unless you've been locked in a
pantry for the last two months by now
you've heard of shut-in daily wire's
latest original film
if you have not seen shut-in you really
should one of the things that surprised
us after releasing the movie is we found
that there were certain themes that
really resonated with our audience
particularly the drive of the main
character a mother who would do anything
she needed to protect her children so we
cut a new trailer that i think really
captures that and we released it for
mother's day take a look
mama
why are you in there
i messed up real bad
[Music]
i'm a bad mom
it's l m n o p
[Music]
daddy's not bad okay
she's sick
[Music]
just like mama was sick
but i got better
jessica
[Music]
i can smell the weakness from here
did they teach you hope and rehab
i'll come back when you're back to your
old self rob rob owes me money don't you
touch my kids
mommy please come out i'm scared i can't
get out
you can't get out you just need to try
harder
you go back to the same miserable life
he has drugs to get away from
please let me out
[Music]
what good is this doing now
[Music]
i'm a bad mom
but i'm trying
let's practice my abcs okay a b c d e f
g
shut in has an audience rating on rotten
tomatoes of 96 it's that good here's the
deal when you sign up for a membership
with the daily wire to watch movies such
as shut in you help us stick it to work
hollywood by helping us build
entertainment alternatives we've just
committed 100 million dollars to
creating dw kids because disney wants to
indoctrinate your kids so head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe sign up for a
membership and don't miss shut in that's
dailywire.com subscribe together
we can build a future that we believe in
we'll be right back with a lot more
identity politics is not working quite
like it used to for the past 20 25 years
all the democrats needed to do
was throw the word racist at someone and
it would destroy that person okay and it
would make everyone cower and fear it's
the worst thing that you can possibly be
called
they would wield
woke identity politics to get whatever
they wanted it was a total get out of
jail free card
that is not working as well anymore and
i think someone who perfectly
exemplifies how little that is working
is chet hanks chet hanks is one of tom
hanks's sons he is one of my absolute
favorite figures in the culture
he talks kind of like a
rapper and he first came to my attention
at least when his parents got kovid and
and he he came on instagram and he said
hey y'all it's chet here yeah my parents
have covid crazy right and i thought no
the crazy thing is that you are chet
hanks what do you how is this tom
hanks's son and he's he's made jokes
about the vaccine and he's made jokes
about political correctness and the
culture and he just seems great i just
really like him as a cultural figure so
anyway chet hanks was talking to a tick
tock star
zee wee a woman with whom i was not
familiar before
zee we asked chat if there are any
marginalized communities that just in
general he as a white man wants to
apologize to here's his answer
are there any marginalized communities
you want to apologize to i don't know
maybe the pot talk community
[Music]
no
i don't feel like i've truly done
anything offensive so
you don't see it as cultural
appropriation you see it as like a
celebration of culture
and then it's like social justice
warriors can like go kick rocks yeah
yeah
yeah
no comment got it no i mean i i 100
agree social justice warriors can kick
rocks
it's not no comment z-way says okay so
you're just refusing to ace no no i'm
not i'm not refusing to answer i am
fully answering they can kick rocks i
will not apologize for being a dude i
won't apologize for being a white guy i
haven't done anything wrong i'm i'm not
evil by virtue of
my race and sex it's not wrong that i
have adopted certain aspects of what you
are suggesting is a black culture or
some other kind of ethnic culture no
that's not wrong it's it's obviously a
catch-22 by the way for white guys here
because
if you do adopt characteristics of
another culture
then you are accused of cultural
appropriation
but if you don't adopt traits of another
culture you're accused of cultural
erasure or eurocentrism or any of these
other kinds so you're damned if you do
and damned if you don't and he says look
i haven't done anything wrong i've just
spoken the truth as i see it i've
behaved in a way that i don't i don't
think is immoral i'm actually just
encouraging people to go sort of
exercise and you know think the right
things and so no i'm not going to
apologize for anything sorry
um but
but you you are a white man
i am yes and so but you're not going to
apologize for that uh no i don't i don't
think that i will why should he that
that would be so crazy that would be so
crazy and i'm glad that people finally
have the confidence again to say no
we're i'm just going to reject the whole
premise here
that we have this hierarchy of races and
certain races need to feel really bad
about themselves and other races are
they're the good races and this this
idea that men are just intrinsically
evil and awful and they gotta put no
we're not gonna do any of that sorry
speaking of young controversial men i
meant to get to this last week but i'll
get to it now
madison cawthorne madison cawthorne is a
freshman member of congress young guy
young conservative member of congress
and boy has he been in the headlines
lately boy has madison catherine been in
the headlines oh man it seems like this
guy can't do anything right he uh
just about two weeks ago there were big
headlines about how
madison cawthorne might be guilty of
financial impropriety or insider trading
because he invested in a in a crypto
coin and then there was another headline
madison cawthorne was caught driving
with a a license revoked because he had
had some speeding tickets that he hadn't
paid yet and then last week this was a
really weird one there was this video
that leaked
with madison cawthorne and it looked
like he was
not wearing very much clothing and he
was kind of like he was i don't know it
was like doing something on a couch with
a buddy of his or something they were
kind of he was like yelling and i don't
know i didn't didn't watch it all that
closely
and and so but people were saying this
is really weird this is a shocking
scandalous video and
i thought huh
why
why is everyone going after madison
cawthorne right now
because none of these none of these
scandals in particular seem all that
just it's not like there was an actual
sex tape of him that leaked it's not
like he was caught committing some crime
on camera or something it wasn't like
kind of a strange video but i know there
are lots of strange videos and then
driving while his license was revoked
that's is that the when i think of the
crimes that
members of congress regularly commit
that seems pretty low on the list and
then he invested in some
in some stupid crypto coin that that's
what why are they go oh i i remember why
they're going after him because madison
catherine blowed the whistle on their on
their coke-fueled orgies just a few
weeks ago
the sexual perversion that goes on
washington i mean it being kind of a
young guy in washington with the average
age of probably 60 or 70.
and i look at all these people a lot of
them that i you know i've looked up to
through my life i've always paid
attention to politics guys that you know
then all of a sudden you get invited to
like well hey we're going to have kind
of a a sexual get-together at one of our
homes you should come and i'm like what
what did you just ask me to come to yeah
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an orgy yeah or or the fact
that you know there's some of the people
that are leading on the movement to try
and remove you know addiction in our
country and then you watch them do you
know a keyboard cocaine right in front
of you and it's like wow this is this is
wild
when madison catherine made these claims
i was not totally sure that he was
telling the truth or that these things
were actually happening i thought it was
likely that what he was saying was true
but i wasn't totally sure
now that
pretty much the moment he made those
comments on air
now that
every single day it seems there is a new
negative headline there is a new hit
piece against him i am now 100 certain
that what he was saying
was true
and look we we know that washington dc
is extremely corrupt we know that
members of our government are very
frequently degenerate and we know that
they've all got blackmail on one another
okay that has been true for
at least the blackmail part has been
true for the entire history of politics
but what clawthrone here is describing
is now actually happening because in
that interview he says look and the way
that everyone covers it up is everyone
says look you shouldn't say this thing
you shouldn't vote this way you
shouldn't do this thing because we've
got some videotape of you or we've got
some arrest record of you or we've got
some bats that would sure look bad in
the headlines and they're all
using this dirt to control one another
this is the this is the plotline of the
of house of cards this is you see this
throughout lbj's life and that robert
carobiography of lbj in particular
you wielded blackmail and so i totally
buy it madison catherine when he made
these claims
the republican leadership too we got
really angry with him
oh boy did they come down hard on him
and he sort of recanted it a little bit
but not totally and they're obviously
just pressuring him and now they're
trying to send a message
um this is another example of i think
the tactics are backfiring here
okay i think the tactic of sending angry
mobs to the conservative justices homes
they thought that that was going to give
them the outcome they wanted i think
really it's just i hope it's hardening
the justices on this and it's certainly
hardening the american people you can
see
even just since the leak came out you
can see momentum moving in the pro-life
direction same thing here if i was 50 50
on madison cother and talking about the
coke-fueled orgies in washington dc i'm
now more like 80 20. i'm now more like
90 10 here i'm now pretty certain that
what he's saying is true because the the
intimidation campaign against him is so
blatant
i i refer to myself occasionally as
nostradamus well look at what catherine
did talk about a crystal ball he said
look they're going to start leaking a
bunch of stuff about me if if i talk
about their coke-fueled orgies and then
what do you get two weeks later speaking
of
anti-constitutional attempts to shut up
conservative members of congress
we've got some good news a judge has
tossed out a challenge to marjorie
taylor green's candidacy
we covered this a few weeks ago on the
show
georgia congressman marjorie green
is very popular among conservatives and
there there was a move by a left-wing
organization to try to kick her off of
the ballot and they tried to kick her
off of the ballot using this very silly
provision
of the 14th amendment to say that uh
if you've engaged in an insurrection
against the united states that you can't
hold public office and so the libs are
pretending that the horn hat guy dancing
around the capitol was an insurrection a
coup d'etat
goodness gracious the government almost
fell and and so they're trying to to
prevent marjorie green from appearing on
the ballot why are they doing that
because they know that they can't beat
marjory green at the ballot they know
that if she's on the ballot she's going
to win because the voters like her
but the the left does not like her
and so they're trying to boot her off
they're trying to do the same thing for
trump this is really just a test run to
see if they can prevent trump from
running for president in 2024 and the
decision
came down
fortunately green will appear on the
ballot i guess ultimately it rests with
the georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger uh but it would be highly
unlikely that he would kick her off of
the ballot so the judge has basically
let her candidacy go through
when i think about marge right i don't
know marjorie green i haven't even
followed her career very closely
but when i see stuff like this it makes
me more inclined to like her if look
there are a lot of members of congress
you can't keep up with all of them you
can't follow the minutia of all of their
lives but if all i know about marjorie
greene is that some of the worst people
in this country are trying to subvert
and pervert our law to prevent her from
even running for office they're so
scared of her
then i guess i kind of like her
right i guess i don't know i don't know
everything about her but just as a rule
of thumb if the worst most radical
leftist people in the country don't like
somebody that's at least a good
indication that that person is actually
doing something in washington dc
they're trying to
wield the state to suppress us
they are trying to
wield the state in ways that are not in
keeping with our history not in keeping
with the rule of law
to prevent us from having
self-government nowhere is this clearer
than the ministry of truth that the
biden administration set up just a
couple of weeks ago
right after the elon musk news broke
that elon musk was maybe going to take
over twitter and conservatives might
have a little bit more free speech on
just one of the social media platforms
within hours the biden administration
announces we are going to set up a new
disinformation governance board to
prevent the spread of disinformation
now
when the the binding administration was
asked hey hold on are you saying you're
going to censor americans they said no
no this is just about foreign
disinformation this is not focused on
american citizens this is just focused
on people abroad
then the conservatives raised the
question hold on then why is it at the
department of homeland security
why isn't this at the state department
oh actually there already is a
disinformation agency at the state
department there already is an agency
that does the same thing that you are
saying that this agency will do
focusing on disinformation abroad
so why create a new one
in a domestic agency oh because you're
obviously just trying to censor
americans
and rand paul
just absolutely ripped the secretary of
homeland security a new one over this
ministry of truth
do we have policies do we have guard
rails do we have here's the problem we
can't even agree we can't even agree
what disinformation is
you can't even agree that it was
disinformation that the russians fed
information to the steele dossier if you
can't agree to that how are we ever
going to come to an agreement on what is
disinformation so you can police it on
social media i think you've got no idea
what disinformation is and i don't think
the government's capable of it do you
know who the greatest propagator of
disinformation in the history of the
world is the us government are you
familiar with mcnamara the pentagon
papers
are you familiar with george w bush and
the weapons of mass destruction are you
familiar with iran contra
i mean think of all the debates and
disputes we've had over the last
50 years in our country
we work them out by debating them we
don't work them out by the government
being the arbiter i don't want you guard
rails i want you to have nothing to do
with speech
now rand paul is taking a really
interesting tack here to go after this
biden administration policy the
censorship ward because he's basically
attacking them from the left
he's saying you know the the united
states government spread a lot of
disinformation in the vietnam war and
george w bush and he's kind of he's he's
parroting lines that would have been
considered left-wing lines in the 60s in
the 70s in the 2000s
he's he's just throwing the libs lines
right back at them
to say why
why on earth have you shifted your
position here why are you pretending now
that the government doesn't have an
interest to push disinformation because
of course it does it this isn't even an
anti-american sort of line to use it's
just a simple fact governments
have an interest in pushing certain
propaganda and so
if the government is going to get into
the business of regulating speech rand
paul takes an extremely libertarian
position here i don't take that
libertarian position i think there are
plenty of
regulations that that our government
traditionally has had on speech on
obscenity on threats on fighting words
upholding standards but the government
has done it in a very careful way in a
in a nuanced way
in a way with lots of guard rails and
then joe biden's going to come in here
like a bull in a china shop and just set
up a censorship board to try to shut
down all the conservatives on social
media because me and old elon is going
to maybe let us get a word in edgewise
really important to see how absolutely
cynical this is do you think that's
going to play for the democrats in
in november i don't think so i don't
when you can attack them from the right
and the left i don't think that's going
to play very well
conservatives need power
conservatives need power in the culture
in the politics and we need to wield it
this is why i'm so pleased to read the
headline who knows if it's true or not
but the report at least from cnbc is
that not only will elon musk
buy twitter but that he's actually
expected to serve as the temporary ceo
of twitter for at least a few months
after the deal completes
i love this in part because
it's just been so delicious to watch
elon musk toy with the twitter
leadership like a cat toys with a mouse
and get them to try to say say oh no
we're happy that elon's coming actually
no we really like that the ceo paragraph
said no i'm really happy and we're going
to work together and elon's like yeah
yeah we're going to we're going to work
together and then just yeah i'm taking
your job actually no we're not going to
work together you're gone
you're fired totally just channeling
donald trump here
so the reason it's important though
beyond just how delicious it is to watch
the twitter leadership squirm is if elon
really wants this to matter he's got to
run it
personnel is policy
if he just buys it and becomes the big
investor and doesn't make huge personnel
changes
and better yet doesn't run the company
himself for some period of time
nothing is really going to change
this is this is a lesson that
conservatives can learn when we win
elections we can win elections but if we
are not actively in there running the
government
we are not actively in there just
putting all of our people into all the
important positions of power and doing
our best to fire all the libs who are
actually making the decisions in the
government and replace them with good
solid conservatives then it's not going
to matter that we win the election the
government is just so big and unwieldy
we've got to go in and actually make
sure that the election means something
is because the difference between the
lifers the careerists in washington dc
and the elected guys is the elected guys
come and go
every eight years every four years
sometimes every two years and those
career guys are going to be there so
where's the real power
the real power is in the people who are
actually affecting these policies
now
it's not enough just to count on big
daddy elon
i like elon
he seems to have a pretty good head on
his shoulders he's doing pretty great
stuff in the culture right now i'm very
grateful for the things that he's doing
i think
what elon musk is doing right now
in in especially the private sector is
is some of the most important stuff
we've seen in my lifetime
but
it's not enough and he's he's not even
really a conservative right
he's much more conservative than most
people but elon made this point himself
he posted a meme where he said that ten
years ago he was center left and then
the left went completely
radical
and so they moved the center
way further left and so now i guess he's
center right
so it's good i'd rather have
a 2012 democrat
over a 2022 democrat running things
because the 2012 democrat is relatively
much more conservative but that's not
going to be the answer i my version of
conservatism is not just whatever the
democrats were doing 10 years ago
my version of conservatism is conserving
something conserving something deeper
and truer and with greater tradition
and
and and that that is in in accord with
the natural law and eternal truths in a
transcendent moral order okay we need
more you see this at tesla right now we
covered amazon last week amazon uh
offering to pay for its employees travel
out of state to get abortions if roe v
wade is overruled
unfortunately tesla is apparently going
to do the same thing
according to tesla's 2021 impact report
the company added travel and lodging
support for those who may need to seek
health care services that are
unavailable in their home state
and this is going to be in their health
insurance offerings
reportedly
that's going to include abortion
do i blame elon musk for this not really
no i mean is the guy supposed to be mr
conservative all of a sudden no i don't
think he's ever presented himself as
such what does elon musk think about
abortion i'm not totally sure i do know
that elon musk has said that we don't
have an overpopulation problem in the
world we have an underpopulation problem
so that's good makes me think he's kind
of he's got he's in the right direction
on life but i can't you can't expect
this guy to just be mr conservative and
transform the whole culture back to
conservatism no
we have to do that the political
community has to do that the supreme
court justices have to do that the
presidents who appoint the supreme court
justices the people who go out there to
to elect conservative representatives
and go and we we have to wield that
power okay and we need to create the
political conditions that make it easier
for a company like tesla to not cover
these things i i made this point last
week
capitalism is great you know i love free
markets i love private property i do i'm
not i'm not being glib or flippant about
that but i don't worship at the altar of
the market i don't worship at the altar
of the market because i think sometimes
the market can get things wrong i think
it is in amazon's market interest to pay
for the travel for its employees its
female employees to go get abortions
because it will make those female
employees more productive
they won't be taking maternity leave
okay they won't be raising children they
won't be calling out of out of work when
their kid's babysitter doesn't show up
or when the kid gets sick
so it's in the economic market interest
of amazon to encourage abortions it's in
the economic market interest of tesla to
encourage abortions
and it's in the political interest of
our community
to
outlaw abortions
it's in our national interest markets
are great but they are an instrument
toward a good society you don't want to
put the cart before the horse okay
they're actually for something
and so what we need to do is go in and
wield that power and if we say look
abortions are just not allowed sorry
we're just not we're not killing babies
that's not what we do as a country
anymore then amazon and tesla those are
going to be the rules and amazon and
tesla and other corporations aren't
going to have to compete with one
another to try to offer their employees
all the best sorts of uh healthcare
plans with the most stuff and the most
freebies and the most
out of state travel covered for abortion
they're not going to have to they're not
going to have to worry about other
companies who are paying for abortions
for their employees having uh cheaper
labor costs then they're not going to
have to worry everyone's going to be on
an even playing field and it's going to
be a much more just playing field that's
what we have got to do okay
we need structural improvement here
we're talking about this this number
came out just last week gas is up
80 percent almost since joe biden took
office 80
that is such a huge spike in what 14
months
a massive not even 14 months at this
point a massive massive spike
in gas that's it's not just because of
markets it's not just because of the war
in ukraine it's because of structural
problems structural problems on energy
structural problems on
how even the states relate to the
federal government we've got to go in
there and wield that political power and
make things better joe biden is the
direct cause of the problem but the
problems run a little bit deeper and
conservatives need to grow a spine grow
some muscle and get a little bit more
muscular as we look ahead to the future
of our country i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor chief and co-host of morning
wire on today's episode protesters
gather outside supreme court justice's
homes new data shows some industries
returning to pre-pandemic levels while
others struggle and one major film
studio refuses to cave to chinese
demands
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire